well this is just an educated guess but
Zima Zima how does it cancer drugs yeah
basically candy corn and Zima fun fact
ingesting candy corn and Zima is exactly
how life cereal monkey died which is
probably why I've been in such a great
mood
Archer no self-respecting alky would
ever say they were in a good mood from
drinking Zima we can beat cancer with
this medicine
you can't man your first mistake was
getting your drugs from a place called
neighborhood drugstore how many more of
these Rambo moments do we need to see if
the person fitting themselves with all
their weapons and clothing it's been
cliche for so long even the joke making
fun of it is cliche now wearing
sunglasses indoors and a knife which I'm
going to push very slowly into your
urethra Archer is supposedly torturing
this pharmacist but all I hear is
foreplay seriously these potato heads
have to be the unsexiest mob of all time
Irish his dish you have any idea who our
boss is nope but a hundred people
surveyed number one answers on the board
I gotta tell you a family feud actually
played out like this I would be the
biggest Steve Harvey fan in the world
okay kid he is a kid Archer he is look
all that much younger than this guy and
really at what point does someone reach
tortured me for information years old
anyhow you're in the isolation booth but
why would she be in the isolation booth
if you're still in the survey and steel
room show doesn't know how to Family
Feud correctly here in Brooklyn numbers
protection dope prostitution as we soon
find out he has very intimate knowledge
of archers mom which means Malory should
already have a good idea he's involved
and all this torture preamble is
extremely unnecessary oh my god this
bathroom has a metal trash can with a
lid this might be a bigger crime than
switching out cancer drugs with sugar
pills how you holding up not great as
you can see I've got wine coolers on my
feet
wine coolers are the equivalent of what
Archer was taking for chemo Archer was
wearing our wine koozies or as I like to
call them my koozie shoes he's never
thought I'd say this but I really miss
the Zima not as much as the makers of
Jolly Ranchers - you seriously those
sales must have gone way downhill after
they stopped producing Zima also make up
your mind about how you feel about Zima
Archer I mean was I there for every
single recital and lacrosse game No
writers do a fine job bringing some
laughs no matter what is going on but
this is clearly the archer goes on a
chemo rampage episode and all this
Mallory Ponder's her mothering side
quest can't help but screech things to a
halt
of course I translated this card and of
course it says good morning I have
breast cancer and of course the show
will continue to get sins off because it
just can't stop making me giggle because
I grew up in resist old County Rhode
Island and now we are on to the Krieger
is a Nazi scientist see plot you think
at some point shows would realize that
22 minutes isn't a ton to fill and you
actually can fill the whole thing with
the same extremely interesting adventure
instead of equipping us with three
separate plots I'm not sure what is more
sinful here that they want us to believe
Archer could fit his medical stand-in
Lana's tiny car that Archer collects
airplane vomit bags or that we could
still see any of that steering wheel
with Lana's giant man hands are all over
it littering an assault assault ring yes
Archer I saw your scarf well all my hair
fell out on your first day of chemo uh
uh it's not good huh no dear afraid it's
just not responding to those chemo drugs
but what in the hospital realign she's
not taking the right drugs and wouldn't
they also be giving her the correct
drugs
I'm sure scams like this happen but
Jesus our checks and balance system
seems to be the real enemy he tried to
psych myself up for every new rock
moving well we'll just see what miss
Archer has to say about this Nazi
beeswax fine or you know not fine she'll
probably say to use the beeswax on the
surf boards because surf Nazis must die
or so I hear also how could Cyril not
smell the fire that Krieger started in
the stall you call this a hand more like
a foot stupid card game puns unless of
course they actually are playing the
card game hand and foot in which case
you're playing it wrong either way
here's your day and also kidding it's a
smoke grenade I realized this entire
series could be subtitled they survive
this but with that being said they
survive this Franny Delaney let's take a
walk Oh what is that some sausage joke
yes it is it would be honest compared to
the standards of the show pretty lame
one but 15th birthday you were at the
compound
when they finish bring me the boy if
he's been around Mallory since then how
is Krieger just now realizing this ogre
doesn't Mallory have to press a button
for this to go over the intercom like
this I guess I've just been getting
hot-boxed all day in my car which I'm
trying to sell but fat chance now I bet
it smells like weed and rampage and
vomit how do you forget the vomit yeah
why if we're watching this recording
later how did Archer get the footage to
cut it together like this when I only
had one camera out there and no one was
controlling it unless the show is saying
this is a fully produced movie where all
the real life people reprise their roles
in exactly the same way as the reality
of the show which I guess is possible
but unlikely enough that it should be
more clear if that's what they were
going for and honestly even I'm not
strong enough to continue to pretend to
care if Archer actually holds up so here
are a few more pretend sins liked him
better when he had cancer TV show
introduces a deadly disease for a
character only to magically cure him or
her two episodes later cliche so shut up
and watch my movie from which I really
need a better title challenge accepted
mmph story time the notorious Bettie
rampage
hmm the rampage of incensed venom let
there be rampage
do you have any hobbies I collect spores
molds and fungus make sure you click
that bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it what
Lana I said it was a rampage today huh
science experiments falling from the sky
giant gorilla on the loose just the kind
of excitement we hear at the government
then to notice okay so day two of the
chemo fuelled rampage and Wow how you
holding up they went into the woods
prepared to find death what they found
was a desecration of humanity at the
site which trappers have often referred
to as coffin Rock you go what are you
doing back there
it smells like we go it's like me go I
wake up early every morning and watch
Regis and that smile of his it gets me
through the day is that your final
answer
goodbye Archer tell your mother to give
me a call sometime say hi to your mother
for me okay